الموقع الجغرافي لدوله البحرين جعلها عرضه
للكثير من التحديات وكذلك التهديدات
الانبياء لكن البحرين استطاعت على مدى
سنوات الحفاظ على امنها وكذلك استقرارها
عبر اداره علاقاتها الاقليميه وايضا
الدوليه بشكل متوازن على هامش معرض ومؤتمر
البحرين الجوي معنى هذا لقاء سياده اللواء
الشيخ حمد بن عبد الله ال خليفه قائد سلاح
الجو الملكي البحريني او سياده اللواء
اهلا بك معنا في عسكريه
سياده اللواء البحرين دائما حريص على
استضافه مثل هذه المعارض ومثل هذه
المؤتمرات لكن القيمه المضافه التي تشكلها
مثل هذه المعارض وهذه المؤتمرات بالنسبه
للقوات البحرينيه بشكل عام والقوات الجويه
البحرينيه بشكل الخاص اولا همم
يعني هذه الندوه همم جدا مهمه وهي تسبق
معرض البحرين الدولي للطيران ليوم واحد هي
تستخدم في شركات العالم شركات العالميه
المصنعه للس الى هذه الندوه وكذلك اييه
قائد الكسار لحضور هذا الندوه والالتقاء
والتشاور في ما يستجد من من صناعات
كذلك المعرض البحرين الدولي للطيران اللي
هو طبعا بعد هذا المؤتمر اليوم
معرض جدا مهم وهو يظهر البحرين على خريطه
العالم
ويستخدم
شركات المصنعه لسلاح من جميع انحاء العالم
التي تعرض احدث ما توصلت اليه التكنولوجيا
مع ذلك همم يعني هذا المعرض كذلك همم
القاعده من وزراء ورؤساء الى الاركان
وقاده اسلحه الجو
ليتم اللقاء بين همم الشركات المصنعه وهمم
اصحاب القرار همم
طبعا هذا المعرض جدا المهم لان في همم نسخ
الاخيره الماضيه البحرين وقعت همم ثلاث من
اكبر همم سبقات همم في همم تاريخ العسكري
طيب سياده اللواء يعني البحرين هي مفتاح
امن منطقه الخليج بشكل عام
هذه المنطقه الان باتت عرضه للكثير من
المخاطر والتحديات وربما الحرب حتى في
اوكرانيا صعدت من وتيره هذه التحديات
وغيرت من شكلها سيادتك كقائد سلاح الجو
الملكي البحريني كيف تقيب هذه التهديدات
والى اي مدى القوات الجويه الملكيه
البحرينيه جاهزه للردعه او حتى للتصدي لاي
هجوم او اي تهديدات تتعرض لها البحر
البحرين
بني على اساس همم قوي ومتين همم بدي
الدرجه الاولى للدفاع عن همم يعني اجواء
المملكه
لكن نظرا لصقر حجم البحرين اييه كان هناك
يعني
يعني اهميه
للتوقيع ما يعني
دول العالم
للعمل في تحالف دولي وقبل ذلك البحرين
وقعت اتفاقيه الدفاع الدفاع الخليجي
المشترك صحيح همم تبع تبع هذه الاتفاقيات
وقعنا اتفاقيه اسلاميه كذلك هذه
الاتفاقيات همم يعني همم تعطينا يعني
القوه في همم العمل همم كعضو في التحالفات
همم لكن في نفس الوقت يعطينا دافع لتطويل
قوتنا للمشارك في عضو فعال في اي تحالف
لولي كان او قليل تمام سياده اللواء انتم
لديكم الكثير من المشاريع لكن ابرازها
هناك ثلاثه مشاريع تحتوي على ثلاث منظومات
هذه مشروع
البحرين وكذلك مشروع رماح البحرين وايضا
مشروع صقور حمد اين وصل واين وصلت هذه
المشاريع
في 2017 تم التوقيع على صفقه الطائرات ال
البلوكس 70 وهي احدث طائره اف 16 مقاتله
في العالم ااه المتوقع باذن الله تعالى
بعد سنه ونص تقريبا توصل اول مجموعه من
هذا الطائرات في 2018 تم التوقيع همم خلال
معرض البحرين الدولي للطيران على طائرات
العمودي همم الكوبرا همم
اهل الطائره عموديه مقاتله همم هذا يعني
في وقتنا الحاضر همم
بعدها بسنه تم التوقيع على منظومه
هذه المنظمات الثلاثه هي تعتبر من اكبر
منظمات اللي تتوقعت في قوه الدفاع البحرين
همم باذن الله تعالى في المستقبل سوف يعني
همم تمنح السلاح همم قوه فعاله للمشاركه
من ضمن التحالف الخليجي لاي تهديد تتعرض
الى منطقه الخليج ولكن بالنظر الى نوعيه
هذه الاسلحه التي يمتلكها سلاح الجو
البحريني سياده اللواء بالكامل هي اسلحه
تعتمد على منظومات غربيه او منظومات
امريكيه الكثير من الدول الانبتت تعتمد
على مصادر متنوعه ما هو الهدف الاستراتيجي
للبحرين خلال المرحله المقبله هل لديكم
خطه لتنويع مصادر السلاح ربما خطه مع
الشرق على سبيل النساء
الى تنويع السلاح وكان السبب في ذلك هو
يعني تقلبات السياسيه لبعض الدول يعني
المنتجه للسلاح
لكن البحرين او القياده في البحرين قررت
التوجه الى همم يعني اتجاه واحد او تتخذ
اتجاه واحد وهو يعني همم مصدر سلاح من
الغرب وتحديدا من امريكا البحرين تجد
الامتلاك قطارات 16 بحكم وجود ب 16 من قبل
وتمكنا من يعني من اداء اداره
يعني والسيطره على على يعني على
عليه بكل سهوله
التنويع همم في السلاح قد يشكل مشكله همم
يعني شكل صعوبه لان احنا كدوله صغيره لان
التنويع يستوجب تغيير في همم نظام الصيانه
نظام التسجيل وهمم بحاجه الى قوه بشريه
كبيره البحرين يعني دوله صغيره همم
امكانيات البشريه قليله فاحنا يعني
قيادتنا اتخذت همم هذا القرار لان التوجه
الى سوق واحد فقط وهي السوق امريكي تمام
سلاح الجو الان يواجه تحدي كبير وهو يعني
همم المنظمات المسيره والطائرات المسيره
همم اولا في هذا المجال تحديدا همم الى اي
مدى البحرين تمتلك قدره وكفاءه في هذا
المجال سواء للتصدي لخطر المسيرات او حتى
لامتلاك منظومات طائرات مسيره حديثه
تستطيع التعامل والتصدي لاي تهديدات
تواجهها البحرين
الطائرات المسيره طبعا
تشكل خطر كبير للعالم الاجمع بحكم ان يعني
صنعت هذه الطائرات قبل تصنيع الاسلحه
المضاده لها شكلت خطوره على دول كثيره
الحقيقه همم يعني همم الخطوره ليست في
انطلاق همم يعني اي دوله للطائرات مسيره
انما خطوره في وقوع هذه الطائرات في ايدي
ميليشيات وقانون العلمي
بالقوانين الدوليه
حقوق الانسان كذلك
يعني حصول المنظمات ارهابيه وهذا اللي حصل
اليوم اكبر تهديد لان احنا في منطقتنا هو
المليشيات الارهابيه والجماعات الارهابيه
طبعا
بهذه المنظمات واستهداف
يعني المدنيين والمواقع الاقتصادي في
ديواننا ال- ال- يعني الحقيقه همم
يعني من بعد المعاناه من همم يعني هجوم
هذه الطائرات
تمكنت دول الخليج ومن ضمنها البحرين في
الحصول على منظومات كثيره مضاد للطائرات
المسيره اولا الكشف ومن ثم ل همم
التعامل معها واسقاطها اليوم الى الحمد
اذا تكلمنا عن البحرين ان البحرين لديها
المكانيه همم الممتازه همم والقرات
العاليه في التصدي اللي مثل هذا التهديد